she all day I mean s-she days all day
all day hey it's Fat Tony I declare war
Houston Texas sup man this is a sure off
you know hair loss Angelina sushi all
day is clean I hope it's nice I hope
just bought a bunch of sake and we
danced around basically that was the
good thing about the sushi video really
wasn't a video at all it's basically
Tony and I doing this we created the
sushi roll dance to which is a very
important dance that sweeping the nation
the most important thing about sushi is
it being fresh clean sushi is very very
important you don't want your sushi
sitting out too long I'm a professional
eater I've been eating all my life no
plans to stop okay also terrible this is
terrible a terrible [ __ ] Susan this
doesn't deserve it's not good for my
body I don't know if I should swallow
this really are you okay with that let's
go with you just terrible bro like this
right
it doesn't even taste like rice yeah
that's a grocery store actually tastes
like grade what the [ __ ] this is Tom OH
150.50
all right or JA I thought trader Joe was
supposed to be like better sushi is not
their game they're like macadamia nuts
bro I've got a piece when your tongue
gets tired
these are looking for some sauce get my
pinky in I usually do in our approach
sushi huh here we go okay
okay this'll be my feels a little bit
better it's a little bit more like
loosen up and like ready to go I was a
juicy you know what I mean I can feel
that right off the jump that makes me a
little bit more like into this and if
I'm into it if the sushis into it you
know I'm gonna be more into it standards
delicious not as sushi on a Tuesday like
your week has already started you're
good you're feeling groovy after she was
delicious I'm gonna go for where's your
glass because it wasn't it wasn't one
time cheers - Susheela
where are you searching the face ah
another grocery store give us a hint I'm
out
it's Whole Foods pom pom pom pom
we got more imma stick to the hands yeah
I think it's the most efficient you
notice like Blanco is opening up all my
other senses see this feels right Newton
okay you're into it the first bite is
good but the first bite can be
misleading bite know what I mean
got it wait till it soaks in your tongue
for sure so when you first start eating
sushi first fish I am oh really
yeah you remember you know where you
peer pressure to eat in the sushi no
good like that
the funny thing is like they're all
making fun of me the next day because I
was just on the balcony eating sushi
just like like 11 o'clock at night just
like all out on the balcony
oh yeah I'm like the back deck yeah
because they're eating seriously in
front of everybody a lot of rice rice
dominant sushi in a week I'm gonna say
I'm gonna go give that a two point seven
out of five and say Ralph I'm gonna give
it a three Ellen be a little generous
pretty bland pretty much whatever pretty
brown but I like my sushis pretty basic
ma'am mm-hmm
I like my sushi just like I'm not
digging this more mm-hmm well all right
let's go you feel me on that foundation
like the good rice is so crucial we're
never by bro
I'm gonna go 3.2 3.2 and I'm gonna say
it's from the sushi place close by here
oh come on
I wasn't digging this one man 25 whoa
nothing that point fives being generous
hmm rock and roll's who's right upstate
right the one the closed bar right no my
good right good bass goes hard good base
good news like good fat fish
this is really good it's hard the best
rooster yeah yeah save the best for last
would you say that trader Joe sushi was
the worst as you know absolutely it was
hands down to what do see yes and I was
blindfolded so my senses are more like
I'm more in touch with my taste buds I'm
gonna give us with your floor I'm gonna
give her the same but mm-hmm well I
don't want to hit the five just yet
because I don't know you know I ain't
trying to wipe the sushi first we feast
you love you
Cheers first we face man free sushi oh
yeah baby oh yeah yeah you know I might
do the bank head bounce on some suits on
the sushi over all day